This next clip is is hilarious.
We are seeing the equivalent.
Of competing temper tantrums happening right
now, right wing media that's loyal to Trump
is having a temper tantrum as they realize
Trump's going to leave office.
Trump lost.
Joe Biden won.
None of these ridiculous attempts to steal
the election are going to work.
So that's one temper tantrum on the other
side.
Meanwhile, you have some Trump advisers increasingly
having a temper tantrum that more and more
media are acknowledging that Trump won.
You understand the competing temper tantrums
here.
And the day before yesterday, this came together
and it was just glorious.
I mean, this is this is a pleasure to watch.
And it was made even better by a slight connection
delay between the two people involved.
And this was a conversation between Fox Business
host Lou Dobbs and HUGE, who, by the way,
is a huge Trump himself and then radical unhinged
extremists, Trump adviser Stephen Miller.
So check out this clip.
And what it seems like is happening here is
Lou Dobbs is mad at Republicans for not standing
behind Trump and not fighting more, fighting
to steal an election that Trump lost, by the
way.
And Steven Miller is mad apparently at states
and governors when they seem to then start
getting mad at each other.
The connection delay makes it even funnier.
Lou Dobbs seems mad at Steven Miller, and
it's just a complete fiasco.
And this is truly people who have no idea
what to do.
They're falling apart like a kid who missed
their nap.
Take a look at this.
Can do nothing, Stephen.
Nothing.
It's it's it's wrong.
What's wrong with the Republican Party?
Where is the outrage really on the tens of
millions, tens of millions about with the
of the Republican state Senator Chuck Hagel
are the Republicans?
You're right.
There are the tens of millions of ballots
nationwide.
No signature checks, no citizenship checks,
no residency checks, no checks, no criminal
record checks, not even checking if you're
alive or dead.
Now, of course, with Steven Miller is saying
is absurd.
No, we're not checking if people are alive.
You can't vote if you're dead physically,
you can't do it.
No citizenship check.
You can't even register to vote if you're
not a citizen.
These are the same old tired talking points
that they keep using.
And this conversation kept escalating as Lou
Dobbs claims Republicans have abandoned Donald
Trump.
Take a look.
Are we a third world country or are we a banana
republic?
What is it?
Come to an point of only legal power from
US citizen.
Let me tell you what a president gets four
more years.
Let me and and, you know, from your lips to
God's ears, the reality is that this president
right now is fighting and let's be straightforward
about it.
He's fighting all along.
And Ted Cruz has stepped up to say he'll argue
before the Supreme Court.
Why in God's green earth wouldn't the White
House jump on it?
Why shouldn't they at that right now?
And I'll just say this.
One of the thing, though, if three state legislatures
I just outlined one correction in one state,
but I won't let you.
So I'm not going to let you do this.
I'm not going to let you do that.
I ask a question.
You and I, we're reasonably smart and decent
fellows.
They are reasonably smart and decent.
They just want an election that Joe Biden
won to be overturned without evidence and
given to the man they worship.
These are guys these are recent, reasonably
smart and decent people who just want the
democratic process thrown in the toilet.
And Trump awarded a victory.
They just disagree about how to do it.
Lou Dobbs is mad at Republican senators, while
I guess Steven Miller is mad at Republican
governors.
But now Lou Dobbs demands an answer from Steven
Miller.
Why don't you hire Ted Cruz as a lawyer to
fight this battle?
Why don't you answer me?
That's all I'm asking here, Steven.
Why don't you guys jump and salute Ted Cruz
and say, yes, we want you on the team now?
My God, this is not a time for internecine
nonsense on the part of the Republican Party,
which is watching its blood drain into the
streets because they're gutless.
Consider how absurd Lou Dobbs idea is to hire
Ted Cruz as a lawyer, to steal the election,
hire a sitting senator, to also be a lawyer
from the.
It's just a farcical idea.
And it's actually funny because, Lou, I don't
know if you saw, but Lou Dobbs did something
there that's rarely done on right wing media
to Trump advisers and Trump sycophants.
Lou Dobbs interrupted Stephen Miller and said,
you're not answering the question.
So this proves what we suspected, which is
they do know these journalists do know how
to do it, but they're choosing not to unless
they don't like the answer.
Lou Dobbs in this case didn't like the answer.
So we're seeing everything in the last few
weeks.
We're seeing some rats abandoning the ship
and sort of eating each other on the way out.
We're seeing some rats go down with the ship.
Kayleigh McEnany would be an example of that.
You're seeing people who are going the direction
of sort of like pretending none of this ever
happened.
And it really is like the best comedy team
on television.
You know, Rudy gets covid put Ted Cruz on
the case.
It's laughable and hilarious and it will be
over soon.
I'm not here to tell you help is on the way.
That's not my catchphrase.
It will be over soon is the catchphrase that
that I'm going
with here.
We have a voicemail number.
That number
is two one nine two David Pakman.